for walden's with us uh he was the
former press secretary too boris johnson
has worked with him very closely for a
number of years um
hi good morning were you expecting this
this morning
hello k
uh i've said to you on many occasions in
recent months and i wrote in the times
overnight that boris doesn't do change
he doesn't do apology and he pretty much
doesn't do resignation unless it
benefits him and i was getting very
worried this morning that that he was
actually not only trashing his legacy
but trashing the very tenets of
democracy so all i can say to you this
morning kay is thank god
you know he has finally done the right
thing but what a fast
to be dragged kicking and screaming like
he is is an embarrassment and and what i
hope now i mean here's the situation
right is he going to reappoint the 57
ministers and trade envoys and pps's as
he goes on for that this is all totally
unnecessary the writing was on the wall
and i presume he is going to have to
reappoint people to cabinet and not give
new jobs to people and that would be the
right thing to do and i do hope when we
see the prime minister later that
instead of the usual guff because that's
what it's become i'm sorry to say you
know as an old friend he knows my views
on it on it all it has become that let's
not have all the usual pandering boris
let's have a serious sober statement
that the right conclusion has been
reached that he can salvage some of the
legacy around brexit and around ukraine
and around covid vaccine yes let's give
him that right but let's also have an
orderly transition and that means making
sure that we don't have useless
pointless legislation on the agenda that
they only concentrate on things that
really matter the stuff like solving the
the current cost of living crisis and we
have a sober uh handover what we saw
last night
was beyond farce you know dipping hands
in blood
the revenge stuff on michael gove
pathetic
absolutely pathetic i'm sorry to say and
he has now finally seen that the writing
is not on the wall but it has taken the
resignation of his education secretary
who must be the shortest serving cabinet
minister in history
um and and his new chancellor telling
him the game is up and i think he's come
dangerously close
to
reaching a point where he would trash
his entire legacy he has an opportunity
to today now having resigned to do the
right thing in terms of this speech and
the right thing over the next six to 12
weeks and i hope he takes that
opportunity and i hope he does it
properly because that is what will
define him going forward
okay and as far as what's going on
behind us in number 10 at the moment two
questions what will be happening he'll
be surrounding him and how will he be
feeling
well i i suspect he'll be feeling
utterly miserable
um
but
it's self-inflicted from the very
beginning this has been self-inflicted
he's made missteps all along in the
handling of these incidents and
ultimately it has cost him and the talk
yesterday of i carry on i have a mandate
you know he doesn't have a mandate he
certainly doesn't have a mandate now but
he doesn't anyway he's lost and beth
beth made a little
accidental misstep earlier where she
referred to two-term president and then
corrected himself and that's the problem
i think boris has seen this as a
presidency he has taken his example from
the mayoralty with no opposition and
come into number 10 with the same
presidential plan
and that has cost him so what will be
going on now is that they'll be
you know presumably i mean it could be
that you know he he'll he'll feel very
disappointed but actually prime
ministers when they make the decision
there's that there's a huge weight
immediately comes off their shoulders
and it could be that they're all sitting
around you know probably watching us
throwing things at me um you know um
just saying oh well you know it was
great and talking about
their greatest hits um i hope that
they're somebody in savory preparing for
the next five weeks writing a decent
principled resignation speech and he
should be given credit for you know
for a lot of stuff that's happened but
if you're going to be prime minister
it's a massively difficult job and
you've got to get much of it right and
when you get it wrong you've got to be
brave enough to front up and say that
and i hope that he does some of that
today and i hope that you know that when
we hear the speech
and when we hear the plan for the next
12 weeks we have a somber assessment of
the grave problems that face this
country the grave problems that face
europe and the world with everything
that's going on in ukraine
and the like
and and that we have 12 weeks of calm
where the prime minister can salvage
some of this legacy and we can have an
orderly transition to a new prime
minister and a new government
is that
within him can he do that yes absolutely
yes he can
you know he is i mean it sounds like
he's still kicking and screaming and
didn't want to go but they they've
persuaded him that and i'm glad they
have and i hope that people like you to
harry and david kanzini are close to him
have stood up to him this morning and
said you know i hope that's what's
happened that it's over and they now
help him through this this next period
and he is absolutely capable of that you
know i i've said to you many times okay
he is not a bad man right but it has
unraveled and it is over and he needs to
think soberly about the country and yes
about his legacy and actually his legacy
will be vastly improved if he deals with
the next six to 12 weeks correctly it is
the next test in boris johnson's
extraordinary career and i hope he
reflects on that in the next few hours
and does the right thing
how do you think he'll be remembered
well
i think if he was still here next
tuesday and hadn't done what he'd done
this morning and they booted him out i
think he'd be remembered for only this
frankly i think he's just about been
able to pull it back and i think the
interesting thing is if he was booted
out next week as opposed to now and
going as he has i suspect they wouldn't
have allowed him to continue as prime
minister we would have had an interim
prime minister and that would have been
an extraordinary event so i i think he
will be remembered as a great
communicator um you know you know the
man that he'd absolutely delivered
brexit and got brexit done um you know i
think history tends to judge prime
ministers better you know
you know with a with the benefit of
hindsight um you know and he's done the
right things um
uh around ukraine but i think it will
also remember somebody that that
fundamentally didn't listen
uh and that became somewhat presidential
um and i think that that's the reason
that he's in the pickle and has had to
resign um you know there's great things
ahead i'm sure for for boris johnson he
has great things to offer
i just hope that he can offer them in a
sober sensible and and pragmatic way uh
you know and look he's the greatest
campaigner of his generation and he'll
always be able to say my party got a 80
seat majority and a massive mandate
unfortunately i suspect that
not much of that will be remembered now
because of the events of the last week